[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode the
Kos this is a real different type than
for so the Kos um first and foremost let
me give a shout out to season gaming
seemeth season gaming as a podcast that
has friends friends that I consider
family from Ainsley two-bird wonderful
podcast that you guys really need to
check out right and a quick story one
year we're at e3 and we're at the
rooftop party you know everybody's you
know having a good time and stuff like
that and I got a chance to meet a
famously Bouldin and he's so cool when
we're talking statues back and forth
back and forth and he had a friend there
and I guess his friend looked like he
wasn't you know having such a great time
or whatever so you know listen man I'm
making it my business to make you feel
welcome to talk to you
so me and Burt hit it off we were
talking about Godzilla the movie and I'm
such a Godzilla fan and he's such a
Godzilla fan and we really hit it off
and you know exchanged Twitter
information and you know stuff like that
stayed in contact well I had got a DM
not too long ago and he was like hey but
you know cuz you talk statues you know
back and forth and he's like yo hey but
um are you interested in a couple of
statutes dude I'm someone you know you
know does that a period of time you
start to make space and stuff like that
and Shaughnessy
that they had Premium Format sideshows
conformant
Master Chief I quickly said how much
what's going on let me get to just
PayPal money as soon as possible and I'm
so happy that he thought of me and the
reason why he thought of me but he
explained is because he knew that the
statute will have a great home that you
know I won't be reselling it none of
that stuff and I will keep it for as
long as I am Alive hopefully you know um
because I truly respect you know that
you know he purchased it and he loves
the searching you know so that's the
short conversation on how the statue got
acquired and I give a shout out to the
bird for being such the stand up dude
and he shifted out expeditiously to you
boy and it got in I said y'all my dude
on boxing imma you know link you and
send you to stuff you know so you can
see it um it's truly amazing I I mean I
think for a whole gate actually just
looked at the statute so let's let's get
into this Premium Format sideshows
mark-5 Milne air armor halo combat
Evolved this is from the remastered
edition of the 2011 remastered edition
that they launched from the halo
anniversary game the reason why this is
my holy grail the reason why I love this
character so much and nine times out of
ten you're gonna get characters from me
that's from comic books from cartoons
from my childhood this is when I was a
little bit older this forged the bond
and friendships with the iron Lords
podcast
this turned our saturdays this game
single-handedly turned our sad saturdays
into untouchable untouchable
we got TVs linked TVs together to play
Halo 2 to be a part of a group of
movement of it was just camaraderie
between guys you know and I owe all of
that to Halo if I can single out one
game I mean we played many games but if
I can single out one game I will single
out halo I remember the first time that
I saw halo I mean I've heard about it
before I heard about Bungie before and
it was supposed to be like a strategy
game or something like that for PC and
when Sega fell out of the business
Microsoft stepped in when Microsoft
stepped in you know they needed a heavy
hitter and they said they acquired funny
bungees halo combat Evolved like you
turned into combat Evolved later but you
know it was just halo and I was like
okay I remember going to easy stores
edie games and they had said live
demonstration of the Xbox game console
so I go inside and it looks nice when it
started up a little fold it looks nice
it was looping Victrola was a little
robust but then I'm walking with the in
first person it was the best first
person ever for console you know at that
time we had like doom and stuff like
that and it Wolfenstein but you know
that was mainly on PC and stuff and this
this just just felt different so I'm
walking be done you see you see the gun
right you see it see it I'm walking with
the gun and you know this is how I'm
moving my shoulders because in the game
this is how he feels like he moves and
he went to a dark area and the light
came on at the bottom of a gun you see
the gun right there's a light at the
bottom and that was my aha moment with
halo that was my instant oh my god
moment this is different games has gone
to a whole new level
he is probably my single greatest video
game character Bar None a Space Marine
now we have other Space Marines but for
some reason this game had that journal
sick quad especially that dead that
extra extra that undeniable hit this dis
dis was gonna go this game was gonna be
that game that was going to change it
wasn't kiddie like you know you say
Mario or Crash Bandicoot oh this guy was
in space kicking butt taking names and
as it went on further you know the
series went to five I don't care what
anyone says I love halo now it may not
be the greatest person to tell you about
all the books on all that other crap but
I could tell you I played every last one
thanks shout-out to floored attic for
getting me to play Halo Wars amazing
stuff
this is the reason why Microsoft has
stuck around so long that's why you see
me wearing a Combat Team that's right go
to the teespring store get that Combat
Team it's crazy that we had a house full
of 16 guys playing off for televisions
16 controller just out there busting
bunch fighting each other all night
literally some of the greatest moments
of my life was on clay Avenue that LOCOG
noodles house amazing stuff hold all to
this one senior now a lot of people is
gonna give you a different video a lot
of people is gonna tell you oh it's you
know to hell with how you feel about it
this is my statue this is the statue I
love this is my Holy Grail it is finally
home l and it would be it's gonna be a
little shrine for this bad boy trust me
I got more halo stuff than actors that
stuff you see right there I just pull
what could fit on the table this is that
guy this is the baddest guy in gaming
bar none leave no one behind
[Music]
so this is the part of the video where
I'm gonna ask you to like follow and
subscribe
and also hit the join button hit hit
that joy button hit the join button yes
we're going to pax we have tons of
interviews lined up we are ready faction
the teams are ready to go and we all
media and I hope to cover Halo Infinite
when it launches this year on the Xbox
series X and also all Xbox consoles
because that's going to keep my fandom
going what I want you to do is stick
around watch the videos watch the
pitches of this guy here and all this
glory
trust me this is an amazing statue that
I am so proud to have also go to Lords
of gaming dotnet where you can get all
the dimensions on this statue and all my
previous statues on Kos where you can
also look at great opinion pieces hard
game reviews by lowered attic and also
the last word with lower kognito Andy
Von Teese I've told you guys before if
you are not following Lord ebon tiss for
all that destiny stuff you are insane he
is cutting edge and he's damn sure not
leaving anything out so watch the video
thumbs up give me a thumbs down leave
some comments there cuz I definitely get
back to you guys and I appreciate every
last one see you next week when I give
you another one of these Kos bangers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]